je sais pas si vous avez vu mais apple a
misé sur son site de nouveaux produits
c'est une mise à jour de ce produit là
ça c'est l'ipad pro de l'année dernière
mais également le nouveau macbook air
alors le beige book air on va pas en
parler aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui on va se recentrer sur le
nouvel ipad pro moi j'ai celui là c'est
l'ipad pro de l'année dernière avec
l'apple pencil de deuxième génération le
combo fonctionne merveilleusement bien
ensemble donc aujourd'hui va se poser la
question à savoir qu'est ce que nous
apporte ce nouvel ipad pro de 2020 est
ce qu'il est intéressant
quelles sont vraiment les nouveautés par
rapport aux monnaies de l'année dernière
et est ce qu'au final il faut se
positionner dessus alors avant de
commencer avant toute chose on mange ton
de cette vidéo on est toujours dans le
confinement liés au corona les russes je
peux vous parler de couronnes à des
russes mais si vous avez suivi ma vidéo
que j'ai publié il ya deux jours
peut-être 3o bref peu importe j'ai
publié une vidéo dans laquelle je vous
invitais à vue hier d'envoyer une courte
vidéo où vous présentiez votre vie
durant confinement l'idée c'est de se
rapprocher les uns des autres et de
partager d'ailleurs vous pouvez toujours
venir le faire vous si vous le souhaitez
l'email ses amours @ monsieur le point
fr oui de l'amour du love avec demain
sans faire tomber l'ipad à ce manque en
mieux donc vous pouvez m'en voyez vous
votre vidéo et on va gagner tout de
suite la toute première contribution et
marcia tonne me l'a renvoyé
bonjour les amis pascal de l'essonne sud
l'île de france
un petit coucou ben monsieur re qui
bafoue tous est là pour vous dire que
ici tout va bien tout va bien malgré
qu'on filme on essaie de faire au mieux
je suis dessinateur industriel donc ce
qui permet pas de faire du télétravail
voilà je vous montre un petit peu mon
poste de travail improvisé j'ai la
chance entre guillemets de pouvoir faire
du télétravail
contrairement à d'autres activités donc
je peux m'adapter bien de la chance
et donc quand ça ne va pas que je fais
une petite pause là bas j à prendre un
petit bol d'air à l'extérieur et là
aussi j'ai bien de la chance de pouvoir
le faire donc je pense notamment aux
aujourd'hui son appartement où apparaît
dans toutes les villes où on peut pas
trop prendre donc pensé pour eux pour un
jour aussi qu'ils doivent sortir tous
les jours acheter des médicaments en
tenez le coup ça va passer et courage à
tout le monde
on y croit ce nouvel ipad prendre
n'importe pas de grosse révolution mais
une belle mise à jour qui as
intéressante le gros focus qui est fait
c'est bien évidemment la performance ce
qui est toujours le cas avec l'ipad pro
le fait d'avoir trois modules photo au
lieu d'en avoir un seul sur la
génération précédente
une mise à jour de l'ios et puis surtout
la grosse nouveauté se tient au niveau
de l'axé soir mais ça je vous en reparle
dans quelques instants le premier focus
qui est fait par apple c'est le poids on
nous annonce un ipad pro qui fait en me
dites moi vous avez atterri tout de
travers la savait pas lui ça voilà on
n'est pas la fin on nous annonce donc un
ipad pro qui fait moins de 500 grammes
contre 630 grammes à quelques grammes
très franchement elle l'a le design est
strictement le même vous avez toujours
failli samedi à l'avant pour venir
déverrouiller de tak extrêmement
rapidement par contre un point qui est
extrêmement important et ça c'est
vachement bien et que c'est au niveau de
l'écran apple maîtrise toujours
extrêmement bien ces dalles mais cette
fois ci ils vont plus loin en nous
apportant un taux de rafraîchissement de
120 hertz ça ça va être intéressant pour
apporter plus de fluidité lorsque vous
allez venir scrollé ça va être la même
chose que vous allez visionner des
vidéos et pour tous les usages
professionnels qui pourront nécessiter
du 120 hertz derrière et notamment aux
sites pour la partie divertissement pour
la party gaming
vous allez donc avoir quelque chose de
beaucoup plus fluide en termes de
visionnage un écran aussi annoncé
extrêmement lumineux allant jusqu'à 600
knicks des supers couleurs du tout à des
compagnies enfin quelque chose qui de
toute façon extrêmement bien maîtrisée
de la part d'apple centaines de photos
et c'est là que ça vient intéressante
vous avez pas seulement un seul capteur
à l'arrière comme ce que vous aviez
seront à la génération précédente vous
avez trois capteurs vous avez donc un
capteur de 12 mégapixels c'est votre
capteur principal c'est un grand angle
et vous allez en plus un 10 mégapixels
tenue ultra grand-angle qui vous
permettra un petit peu d'ouvrir les
perspectives
lorsque vous voulez faire les photos et
que vous avez un bâtiment devant vous
par exemple et que vous n'avez pas le
recul nécessaire pour le prendre en
entier ultra grand-angle tac vous l'avez
intégralement dedans et puis il ya plein
d'usagé on peut aussi avoir de cette
manière là lorsqu'on les prend une photo
avec plein d'amis devant vous ultra
grand angle vous les avez on sait que
les ultras grand temps de son très bon
joueur qui a beaucoup
lumières mais dès que vous avez un petit
peu moins de lumière c'est toujours un
peu moins bon bien évidemment je
tendrais de tester ce produit pour
pouvoir vous dire exactement ce que j'en
pense on n'est pas sur un produit qui
est là pour faire des photos comme on
pouvait le faire avec son iphone
notamment comme celui avec l'iphone on
se promet axe néanmoins c'est
intéressant qu'un peu cherche à aller
plus loin pour apporter de nouvelles
solutions par rapport aux différentes
problématiques le troisième capteur est
ce qu'on n'a pas une caméra d'offres
time of life en fait ce que ça va faire
ça bien mesurer la distance entre votre
tablette la personne qui est devant vous
jusqu'à cinq mètres de distance ça
envoie un petit laser qui va aller
jusqu'à la personne qui va revenir ici
et en fonction du temps de réponse aller
retour il va pouvoir connaître
exactement la distance pour apporter un
flou d'arrière-plan s'il voulait faire
des photos
mais il peut y avoir aussi plein de
l'application derrière au niveau de la
réalité augmentée chez apple s'appelle
le scanner lidar on le retrouve dans
beaucoup de smartphones la caméra teuf
et c'est plutôt pas mal que apple
d'intégrer là dessus d'autant plus pour
aller toujours plus loin au niveau des
applications de réalité augmentée parce
que je pas si vous suivez mais depuis
quoi les 2 3 ans apple fait un très gros
focus sur la réalité augmentée au niveau
de ces appareils on sait que tim cook
croient davantage en la réalité
augmentée par rapport à la réalité
virtuelle qui selon lui en ferme
davantage la réalité augmentée apporte
aussi beaucoup d'usagers notamment
beaucoup d' usage professionnel en
termes de maintenance en termes
différentes expériences et comme on est
sur l'outil professionnel ça paraît en
tout cas avoir du sens qui viennent
travailler davantage sur la réalité
augmentée et notamment qui est cette
fois-ci mme keller a tough qu'ils soient
ajoutés au niveau l'expérience audio
c'est toujours la même chose avec quatre
haut parleurs en termes de performances
on a cette fois ci la puce à 12
z on aurait pu s'attendre à voir une
puce à 13 x
donc c'est une à 12 aces donc une mise à
jour de la puce à 12 8 coeurs pour vous
apporter toujours plus de performances
apple nous parle vraiment là-dessus de
montage vidéo 4k de bosser sur de la 3d
bien évidemment toujours la réalité
augmentée et tous les usages
professionnels qu'on peut avoir derrière
qui peuvent en découler notamment de la
création du photoshop du multi calq et
si et ça enfin tous la nécessité
beaucoup performance et d'ailleurs il ya
un très gros focus qui était fait de la
part d'apple as-tu c'est un tout qui est
vraiment intéressant et qui dessine en
tout cas le contour de ce produit mais
qui apporte plus de flou par rapport au
reste de la gamme tout s'explique
c'est qu'en fait il le marquer même dans
le communiqué de presse cet ipad pro est
annoncé comme étant plus performant que
la plupart des pc tournant sous windows
ce dont convient comparer ce produit à
un pc et le focus est fait et a su
mais clairement de la part d'apple en
disant que votre prochain ordinateur
n'est pas un ordinateur c'est un ipad
pro vous allez voir en plus je vous en
ferai dans quelques instants vous avez
des accessoires qui font de cet ipad pro
toujours plus un ordinateur un petit
ordinateur en tout cas un produit
vraiment un mi chemin donc ça vient
petit peu complexifier le message à dire
ok j'ai besoin d'un ordinateur
aujourd'hui est-ce que je pars sur une
tablette ordinateur à usage
professionnel qu'on peut aussi utiliser
un usage domestique par extension sans
aucun problème ou alors est-ce que je
vais sur un macbook air qu'est ce que je
vais sur un macbook pro de quoi est ce
que je vais avoir réellement besoin en
termes d âge et je trouve que ça
complexifie un peu le message en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est que celui là
l'est déjà mais le nouveau prêtre
toujours plus performants toujours plus
pertinents donc ça par contre si à vous
de voir d'ailleurs dès maintenant dites
moi en bas en commentaire qu'est ce que
vous en pensez en termes d'usagé est-ce
que vous pensez que le nouvel ipad pro
même à l'ancien peuvent vraiment avoir
un sens en terme d' usage professionnel
et venir remplacer complètement un pc ou
même pourquoi pas un acte book air
macbook pro ou alors est-ce que vous
pensez que le calme sur deux usages
différents est-ce que vous avez les deux
est-ce que vous avez d'un côté le
macbook pro est ce que vous avez d'un
côté l'ipad pro et quels sont les usages
que vous allez privilégier pour un
produite par rapport à l'autre il ya un
autre point qui a été mis en avant c'est
l'amélioration de l'architecturé
thermique c'est dur à dire les
architectures thermique pour venir à
toujours mieux dissiper la chaleur
améliorer les performances et
l'expérience utilisateur
si vous utilisez sans protection pour ça
évite aussi de lier bouche les doigts la
recharge se fait comme son mandat de
manière odieuse baissé et on nous
annonce jusqu'à 10 heures de performance
soit selon apple
une journée vous savez une manière un
peu la présente et ipad ios c'est un os
c'est comme un os pour ipad a
spécialement dédiée pour ipad pour venir
améliorer l'expérience sur ipad et là
ils ont une mise à jour qui est
intéressante et qui vient notamment
avoir un sens par rapport à un
accessoire qui s'appelle le magic qui
bandent vous exclusivement quelques
instants tout fait juste un focus sur
l'ipad au sc bastia beaucoup papiers ici
ipad os version 13.4 qui vient prendre
en charge le trackpad parce que oui vous
allez voir vous allez pouvoir avoir un
trackpad à vous pourrez mettre à jour
votre ipad dès le 24 mars sous ipad ios
13.4 pour tous les ipad pro quel que
soit le modèle pour l'ipad r à partir de
la deuxième version
pour la cinquième génération de l'ipad
et pour l'ipad mini 4 bien évidemment
tous les modèles qui arrivait après le
nouveau produit intéressant parce qu'il
a également dû
6 vous avez un modèle wifi mais
également un modèle wifi + 4 g ici pas
de 5 g c'est un choix d'apple de se dire
ok sur notre ipad pro pour l'instant on
n'est pas là 5 gs qui n'y croient pas et
ce qu'ils pensent que c'est trop tôt sur
ce produit là on verra tout cas s'il
confirme ce message là avec les nouveaux
iphone au mois de septembre
j'ai du mal à croire que sur les iphone
en septembre apple ne nous propose pas
de 5 g ça me paraîtrait assez déconnant
sur un ipad pro aujourd'hui pourquoi pas
parce qu'on n'aura pas forcément les
mêmes usages qu'on peut retrouver sur un
iphone mais on aurait pu en tout cas
tant de là dessus une version sans doute
affaire à suivre
les accessoires on a donc toujours cette
hype 'le pencil de deuxième génération
auquel vient d'être là dessus le tarif
là c'est 135 euros
mais cette fois ci nous présenter un
magic qui borde un magic qui bordent
incluant un trackpad et ça vient encore
plus complexifiés le message parce qu'on
voit que cette fois ci on a tous du pc
ce produit se positionne encore plus en
concurrence face à ce qu'ils aient
retrouvé au niveau de l'informatique
personnelle sont des pc ou des macbook
ça complexifie un peu le message mais ça
apporte une alternative en plus alors
l'idée de ce match qui borde moi j'ai
trouvé intéressant c'est que vous avez
une fixation magnétique jamais vraiment
pour le prendre en main brand content
pouvez donc le régler à différentes
hauteurs c'est complètement injuste
table vous avez en plus dessus un port
en usb c'est pour venir recharger votre
ipad facilement même lorsqu'elle est
dans votre magic keyboard un clavier
nous annonce un mécanisme à ciseaux avec
une course très courte pas plus de 1 mm
et en terme de tarif vous avez un rail
j'ai noté tout ça ici pour la version 11
pouces
le magic qui borne est à 339 euros et à
399 euros pour la version 12,9 pousse
alors lis pas disparue tout de suite il
sera disponible lui à partir du mois de
mai côté tarifs comme d'habitude si la
peur et ce détail qui sont relativement
élevés sur cette hippologie de produits
mais rien de bien surprenant là dessus
vous pouvez donc le choisir soit 11
pouces soit en 12 pouces si on part sur
la config on se pousse quelle que soit
la couleur vous l'avez en 128 gb à
partir de 899 euros
ça c'est le prix de départ dès que vous
augmentez tout de suite voyait au niveau
du stockage hop vous allez augmenter les
tarifs vous monter jusqu à 1149 euros
si les tarifs de la version wifi si vous
partez sur la version wii fit plus car
j'ai tout de suite les tarifs s'envolent
tandis que si vous changez de
configuration vous allez sur la version
12 9 pouces vous voyez quand inversion
de départ vous partez à 1119 euros vous
monter jusqu'à 1600 69 euros et si vous
allez sur la version wii fit plus 4g
vous monter jusqu au tarif de
1839 euros tout de suite quand même vous
cache pas est un tarif assez élevé même
si malgré tout on a un bail pas de pros
derrière voilà français quelques infos
sur le dernier ipad 3 ce que je trouve
intéressant là dessus c'est
effectivement le fait d'apporter un
écran sans mayotte
ça correspond à sont aujourd'hui au
niveau du marché des smartphones donc
120 yards sur un produit professionnel
ça me paraît complètement légitime le
fait d'aller un peu plus loin en termes
de performances ça me paraît bien je
sois pris connaît pas une puce à 13
dessus peut-être qu'on aurait eu les
mêmes performances
bon en tout cas ça a l'air de
fonctionner donc why not le fait d'avoir
deux capteurs au plus haut niveau de
l'appareil photo pourquoi pas c'est pas
le produit qu'on va plus chercher pour
aller faire de la photo en termes
d'usagé je pense notamment que
d'utiliser son smartphone pour ça et si
on pousse la réflexion un peu plus loin
on se dit ok ils nous mettent un ultra
grand-angle pourquoi pas mais pourquoi
pas été l'objectif est ce que lui tu
racontes angle à un usage supérieurs à
ceux du téléobjectif sur un ipad pro dit
le moment ben comme jacques myard ce que
vous vous en pensez par contre le pacs
trouve extrêmement intéressant et qui
est mon avis tu prend tout son sens et y
apporte le plus d'intérêt ait pas de
fraudes
c'est l'accessoire alors ce accessoires
j'imagine que vous pourrez le maître
sans aucun problème sur l'ipad pro de
l'année dernière puisque vous pourrez le
mettre à jour sur le dernier relations
d' ipad aux us si vous ne venez pas de
première génération je vous pensiez
changer parce que vous avez besoin de
plus de performances ça peut être
intéressant d'aller sur ce nouvel ipad
si vous avez un ipad de l'année dernière
est-ce que vous sentiez les limites et
est ce que vous pensez vous avez besoin
d'un modèle encore plus performant avec
une meilleure dissipation de la chaleur
je suis pas sûr que le coût des caméras
ça vous apporte réellement peut-être
l'écran de 120 air s'est d'ailleurs dit
le mois en bas en commentaire si c'est
le cas sinon le modèle devient les airs
suffira largement que je pense toujours
très actuel est très intéressant mais
surtout avec le magic qui bordent que je
trouve vraiment cool vous mettez en
maintenant vous ce que vous en pensez en
bas en commentaire comment vous trouvez
ce nouvel est pas de trop on est sur un
produit à usage professionnel qu'il est
parfait pour monsieur madame tout le
monde si on veut un ipad de bonne
qualité vous trouverez des produits très
bien moins cher on n'ira pas aussi loin
que se retrouver là pour noah lusage
lassus principal que je verrai vu qu'on
est sur un produit qui vient un peu tout
mélanger l'idée de voir un ordinateur
par du traitement de texte d'un trackpad
on peut venir avec son apple pencil
travailler dessus dessiné pour moi c'est
un produit qui a vraiment tout son
intérêt et tout son adn avec
l'utilisation du stylet c'est à dire
comment les graphistes la 3d le montage
en 4k ouais pourquoi pas ça ne paraît
pas le plus évident mais vraiment pour
tout ce qui m création graphique on a
besoin d'avoir un produit on peut venir
à peu transformé là pour moi ça prend
tout son sens à dubaï est ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire quant à
nous on se retrouve demain on continue à
parler taquet n'oublie pas m'envoyer vos
vidéos pour parler de vous et votre vie
durant confinement à
pour @ monsieur groupe pourrait faire
des bisous des matches a repris mais si
le vario peace paix maintenant tu dis
est faux mais